hey guys my name is Jeff it is the 30th
of August today and you are watching in
Sparky's al filled ones open beta starts
today for battlefield insider members
and tomorrow for everybody else if you
signed up for the free battlefield
insider program before August 21 you'll
be able to take advantage of a special
incentive if you hit rank 15 and play on
at least four different days you'll
unlock a battle field 18 a dog tag which
you can use when the full game launches
on October 21 the open beta takes
players to the Sinai desert map where
you can engage in horseback and aerial
combat the two modes in the beta our
conquest which supports up to 64 players
and rush which supports 24 players a
post from the official battlefield
Twitter account also revealed that
players in the open beta on ps4 won't
need a PlayStation Plus subscription to
play the beta while xbox one players
will need xbox live gold for multiplayer
do I see yet to announce when the beta
will finish next up metal gear solid 5
the definitive experience has been
officially announced as expected Konami
will be releasing the definitive
experience on October 11 in the US and
october 13 in the UK it will include
metal gear solid 5 ground zeroes the
phantom pain and metal gear online as
well as all dlc the game will come to
xbox one and ps4 for 50 bucks while the
pricing for the steam version is to be
confirmed at a later date finally some
cyberpunk 2077 news is never a bad thing
and fortunately today bring some of that
develop a set of her ex rel have posted
a number of curious job listings
suggesting cyberpunk 2077 may have
vehicles one ad calls for a vehicle
gameplay programmer to quote creep a
whole architecture of vehicle related
code and the physics of driving and
flying in those vehicles another is
looking for a vehicle gameplay designer
to create compelling vehicle based
gameplay which includes vehicle handling
controls vehicle combat and relevant
vehicle based AI system I suppose that a
product didn't already have vehicle
developers on stuff since the witcher 3
was pretty light on jet planes and
four-wheel drives the studio currently
has over 60 from positions for the
cyberpunk 2077 team the game is expected
to launch sometime between 2017 and 20
21 so yeah we don't really know head to
gain swept the stories on minecraft and
heroes of the storm and I will catch you
again tomorrow